go is is a very ancient game it's
probably the most complex game humans
play there's more configurations of the
board than there are atoms in the
universe in the game of Go
we need this amazingly complex intuitive
machinery which people previously
thought was only possible within the
human brain to even have an idea of
who's ahead and what the right move is
that we should play there so our program
combines lots of different techniques
together and for the first time ever
alphago our program beat a professional
player it go on even stones so no
handicap on a full sized go board so i
played chess from very young and that
was my first game that i fell in love
with but then when I got to Cambridge
and doing my undergrad there there was a
very strong go Club at Cambridge with
very active players
lots of mathematicians it seems to
appeal to mathematicians the game dennis
was a very very strong game player he's
a child prodigy and one of the strongest
chess players in the world and it was
very important to some people in the
company that we could actually beat dem
estat something and I decided that the
game of Go was my only chance because
Dennis didn't really know the game at
that time from now on I fell in love
with the game and since then I've always
thought it would be a great challenge
for computers to be able to play such an
aesthetic game and intuitive game like
go much greater challenge than it was to
play chess
go is a game for two players it's a game
of perfect information so there's no
luck there's no hidden moves or anything
and the game is played by black and
white take it in turns to place moves
they place moves on the board but these
stones once placed do not move but a
stone can be captured and stones are
captured by completely surrounding them
white is now threatening to capture a
black stone by playing here and
completely surrounding it and the
ultimate objective is to control more
than 50% of the board you look at the
board there are hundreds of different
places that this stone can be placed
down and hundreds of different ways that
white can respond to each one of those
moves hundreds of ways that black can
respond in turn to White's moves and you
get this enormous search tree with
hundreds times a hundreds times hundreds
of possibilities and in fact the search
base of go is too enormous and too vast
for brute-force approaches to have any
chance of succeeding and as a result IO
researchers have to turn to more
interesting approaches than brute-force
search which are perhaps more human-like
in the way that they deal with the
position it's a very intuitive game so
if you ask a great go player how it is
that they decided on a move they'll
often tell you it felt right so these
things are generally computers are not
great at the key to alphago is the deep
neural networks that we use under the
hood so in fact in alphago there are two
different neural networks the first
neural network is something we call the
policy network we also have a second
neural network which we call the value
network and the way that alphago uses
them is to reduce the enormous
complexity of the search tree down to
something more manageable so instead of
having to consider hundreds of different
moves at each step of the search it just
considers maybe a handful of promising
moves that are suggested by this policy
Network
the value network we use to reduce the
depth of the search so instead of having
this enormous lead deep search that has
to go all the way down to perhaps 300
moves all the way to the end of a game
what we do is we search to some modest
depth of perhaps 20 moves and then we
evaluate that position without playing
all the way to the end of the game
to say who is going to win in that
position the search process itself is
not based on brute force it's based on
something more akin to imagination we
evaluate our programs internally against
themselves and we have an estimate of
how strong they are
but we don't know for sure until we test
it against a top human professional and
so I was very exciting when we invited
found ready to come in the current
European champion to come and play
alphago we weren't sure who was going to
win to be quite honest I expected
alphago to expected it to lose albeit
not not by much I was therefore very
interested and slightly surprised I will
admit when alphago did as well as it did
and all credit to it in the end
you know alphago won five nil and you
know it was stronger than perhaps we
were expecting so we've beaten found way
the European champion now we have to go
and demonstrate that we can beat the
world's top players not just the
European top player so we're actually
going to be playing a match in march
against lee sedol who is the greatest
player of modern times he's won more
championships than any other player in
the last decade and he has accepted a
challenge to play alphago and we're
quietly confident but again who knows
what will happen I would put my money
probably on the human but I wouldn't put
lots of money on human humans have
weaknesses they get tired when they play
a very long match they can play mistakes
they are not able to make the precise
tree based computation the
a computer can actually perform and
perhaps even more importantly humans
have a limitation in terms of the number
of actual go games that they're able to
process in a lifetime a human perhaps
can play a thousand games a year
alphago can play through millions of
games every single day it's at least
conceivable that as a result
alphago could given enough processing
given enough training given enough
search power reach a level that's beyond
any human most games are fun and were
designed because they're microcosms of
some aspect of life and there may be
slightly constrained or simplified in
some way but that makes them the sort of
perfect challenge for us as a
stepping-stone towards building you know
general artificial intelligence we're
very excited about what the future holds
both in terms of Google applications you
can imagine within Google actually
taking our interactions with our many
users at Google to try and optimize how
we interact with them in addition we'd
like to consider tasks beyond that
perhaps moving into medicine one day
where we all be able to help patients
personalize their treatment by actually
using reinforcement learning to
understand which sequences of treatments
actually needs the best outcomes of
those individual patients based on their
particular track record and history
in the early days of alphago I played
against it but it was quickly apparent
that alphago is way beyond my skill
level I've not played alphago myself I'm
not strong enough but I've played
through many of the games I did play
much of yourself ago when I was first
introduced to the game and did you win